allait prendre la parole sur la liberté
artistique lors d'une conférence
littéraire dans l'État de New York
lorsqu'il a été poignardé au coup et à
l'abdomen une triste nouvelle pour
l'écrivain Dani Laferrière c'est
toujours quelque chose de triste mais
c'est beaucoup plus que cela c'est pas
seulement un homme qui est attaqué cette
fois-ci c'est carrément je pourrais dire
même c'est l'alphabet c'est les lettres
c'est les livres c'est tout tout
l'imaginaire qui se trouve attaqué on a
plus de droit d'aller au-delà de ce
qu'on sait Salman rush dit 75 ans a été
maintes fois menacé de mort depuis la
parution en 1988 de son roman intitulé
les versets sataniques layatollah Comini
avait même appelé les musulmans du monde
entier à l'abattre jugeant son ouvrage
blasphématoire à l'égard de Mahomet sa
tête avait été mise à prix pour la somme
de près de 3 millions de dollars
américains
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours continué
de porter son message de liberté malgré
les menaces dit la gouverneur de l'État
de New York après l'attaque
d'aujourd'hui l'auteur d'origine
indienne a été transportée à l'hôpital
Paris hélicoptère il a été opéré
d'urgence son assaillant présumé a été
arrêté mais les motifs entourant
l'agression de mornibuleux pendant des
années Salman rouge dit a dû vivre caché
et sous haute protection policière ce
qui ne l'a pas empêché de publier
plusieurs autres livres dont une
autobiographie signée de son pseudonyme
Joseph hanneton
entre les États-Unis et l'Europe Salman
Rushdie ne faisait plus l'objet de
surveillance policière depuis plus de 20
ans il avait retrouvé une vie presque
normale et sans relâche une militait
pour la liberté d'expression ici
Louis-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal